here we are with solomia book
who is my ukrainian teacher but not only
that she is associate professor
of general linguistics at the ivan
franco university here in la vie
and of course we talk about a lot of
subjects in our ukrainian lessons and
one subject that came up and that we're
gonna try to talk about
even in ukrainian but we're gonna start
in english and that is the subject of
solomia's dissertation for her phd which
is frequency and she discovered and she
showed me her work
and there's some very interesting things
that come out first of all that the
frequency of words declines very quickly
so
the most frequent words might have
several thousand like in the top ten
might have several thousand uh
appearances in any given text and then
even within the top three thousand
the last
few hundred may only have ten
appearances so there's a very dramatic
drop right decline decrease in frequency
that was the first conclusion you had
and the other one was that it it happens
no matter what the genre is in other
words it can be everyday speech it can
be a newspaper type language it can be
scientific language the the
decline or the decrease in the frequency
is the same right and it's the same for
all languages
uh it seems so the core vocabulary is
very
similar
the first
let's say 100 or even 500 words
are
100 or 500 most frequently used words
are
universal for all
languages and
creating kind of core vocabulary
and of course the most frequently words
are
conjunctions prepositions
particles
and then
verbs nouns adjectives into adverbs
so what i took out of that because my
interest i'm not a scientist i'm not a
linguist but how does this apply to
language learning so i googled to see
what people are saying about wordless
and no one seems to have done the work
that you and your colleagues have done
where they look at five different genres
thai styles okay themes subject areas so
i thought that was very interesting and
the other thing that i got out of it was
that
as with our mini stories at link you can
attempt to write
material and i think this is the purpose
of these lists to help people who are
writing textbooks so you can write
textbooks based on the very high
frequency words
but once you get past this very early
list the the frequency drops so quickly
that
and we've tried that link to create
intermediate level text but it becomes
difficult because in fact the frequency
declines so quickly
that maybe people are better off to look
at particular
areas of interest to them
for you know daily conversations
sports music and then to use authentic
material
rather than to attempt to deliberately
write
textbooks based on these
even though relatively high frequency
still
not very high frequency words that was
my sort of preliminary conclusion am i
wrong
you're allowed to disagree
of course you are right and
some people could think
to be able to speak any language you
have just to
learn by heart these frequently used
words from the list
but actually
we know
the best
thing to memorize to remember the words
is the context ideally is the
interesting
context so that's why
um
the
practical application of these frequency
lists
are
to give the material
for the potential authors of the
textbooks to use them
in their textbooks
and
of course if they are creating the
stories
by the way you have really good stories
in your link thank you
[Music]
they will use some other
unique local frequently used
words
so to sort of conclude this not very
scientific discussion here
i think her work is very interesting the
frequency the the rapid decline of
frequency which i hadn't realized the
fact that it's common to different
themes in the language and it's common
to
all languages based on other research
and of course the fact that we should uh
not try to learn from these lists
and the people authors of textbooks can
try to use the very high frequency words
for beginners and thereafter we've kind
of we sort of have to fend for ourselves
but we're best to try to focus on
specific areas of interest so that at
least there will be deliberately
creating more frequency for ourselves
okay and we're gonna i'm gonna try to
cover this in ukrainian and it's going
to be very very difficult okay by the
way how did you use the
idea of frequency in your
link system okay well really
briefly so one of the things we do is we
indicate the frequency of a word so if a
person comes across a word
then they may be more interested in
learning it if they find out that it's a
high frequency word i don't know if
learners use that and the other thing we
did is we wrote our mini stories and
based it around the highest frequency
verbs because
my feeling was that i need the verbs in
order to speak and the many stories are
there to get me to speak earlier and
they have been effective so i found
myself speaking earlier in persian or
arabic or greek than i did in say czech
or ukrainian even though
because i had studied to say russian
they should have been easier because
they're slavic languages so to that
extent we used it but now having seen
your material i'm going to look at other
ways we can use it it could be
interesting absolutely okay
bye for now
you